[Música]
ah
i
alguna vez se preguntaron por qué
algunos chicos quieren aprender y otros
no
alguna vez se preguntaron por qué
algunos chicos se motivan se esfuerzan
perseveran y triunfan mientras que otros
tal vez se frustran y abandonan mira
cuando lleva al colegio iba al colegio
de mujeres hace muchos años atrás y en
educación física armaban grupos armaban
equipos y cada año durante toda la
primaria y toda la secundaria habían
diferentes capitanas y éstas capitanas
eran las que salían a buscar a las
compañeras en este colegio de mujeres
para armar los equipos entonces teníamos
equipo rojo equipo azul equipo verde
amarillo y teníamos otros equipos
dependiendo del año la cantidad de
chicas pero me acuerdo que las capitanes
de ambos a mi equipo base a mi equipo 2
a mi equipo ya mi no me lejía nadie
nunca en algún momento decía no te decía
primeras porque sabía que primera no me
van a elegir nunca pero por lo menos
penúltima un poquito de dignidad y
tampoco alguien le pasó esto levanta
hermano que le pasó viste que te sentís
horrible sí
y ahí me di cuenta o muchos años después
pensando en esto me di cuenta en
realidad
que muchas situaciones envían un mensaje
silencioso pero muy poderoso y me di
cuenta que hay una relación muy pero muy
poderosa entre mentalidad y logros y
creo que puedo o sí creo que no puedo
quienes de ustedes nunca pudieron
aprender a manejar porque pensaban que
no podían o porque alguien les dijo que
no iban a poder y quien alguna vez tal
vez nunca aprendió a cocinar porque
pensaban que no podían o porque alguien
les dijo que no podía cuántas veces no
estos mensajes nos llegan y nos marcan
te voy a presentar anita anita es mi
hija han ido y tiene nueve años en esta
foto tenía siete y lo que te voy a
contar tiene que ver justamente con una
situación que pasó cuando ahorita tenía
7 años y estaba en segundo grado del
colegio
la cuestión es que un día nos llegó una
nota del colegio en donde nos dicen que
los chicos tienen dictado de números en
inglés del 1 al 12
o sea que decían one y anita tenía que
escribir o n
perfecto la cuestión es que yo me iba de
viaje a dictar un curso y no me podía
ocupar
yo soy profesora de inglés nada me da
más placer en la vida que cuando me
puedo sentar con anita a trabajar en
cuestiones de inglés entonces le pido a
mi guel que es mi esposo si él podía
ayudarla y miguel me dice que sí que no
tiene ningún problema que él se encarga
miguel está conmigo hace 18 años y del
que está conmigo miguel ha podido
mantener muy bien su nivel de inglés que
es algo así como un principiante bajo
o sea más bajo no hay lo vi llenar
miguel con su lobby giner me dice yo me
ocupo y mami que se iba de viaje pero es
bastante controladora agarra el celular
y empieza one
o sea yo me voy pero me quedo y la clase
se hace conmigo ese día que yo me iba de
viaje junto con miguel la buscamos anita
en el colegio para ir a comer a algún
lugar para pasar más tiempo juntos
anidaba doble escolaridad al colegio la
mañana y a la tarde
íbamos un local de estos de comida
rápida van entendiendo algunas
cuestiones personales estamos en este
local de comidas rápidas y entras justo
una amiga de anita también de 7 años
también segundo grado con la mamá y se
sientan con nosotros la amiguita de
anita que sabe que yo soy profesora de
inglés michele a vivir rival mañana en
el colegio vivir bárbaro además si te
llega a ir mal y salta la madre la mato
la mato si le va mal yo con mi
hamburguesa le guiñó el ojo la mamá la
miro a la nena y le digo de bir bárbaro
además si te llega a ir mal y salta de
vuelta a la madre y me dice no salen
todo el fin de semana y ya lo hablamos
con el padre
bueno la llevamos a las chicas del
colegio yo me voy de viaje a dictar el
curso y miguel vuelve a trabajar a la
tarde cuando vuelve anita a casa empieza
con la clase de inglés con miguel mi
esposo miguel agarré el celular como muy
bien se lo había instruido y qué hace
lo revolean o lo conoces a miguel y
empieza la clase a su manera entonces
miguel explica anita que es el número
tres es como árbol pero con h
cuando llega eleven que es 11 le explica
anita que eleven es el event
eleven
el event
reconoce me que tú eres 12 es difícil no
para miguel para miguel fe es twv el b
[Aplausos]
y así va a mi pobre hija al colegio a
rendir su dictado de inglés
la cuestión es que esta noche cuando yo
llego me dice anita más me fue re bien
en inglés buenísimo le digo y salta
miguel contarle a mami cómo te explique
y ahí me cuenta yo pero para vos fuiste
al colegio y hacías el event y me dice y
me acordaba de papi
la cuestión es que no solo le fue muy
bien a anita en el dictado sino que la
pasó genial y además es el día de hoy
que se sigue acordando de todos los
números
anita va a tener 140 años y se va a
seguir acordando cómo se escribe
actuados cómo se escribe y le ven y cómo
se escriben todos los números como le
fue la otra nena y la verdad que no sé
nada para llamar a la más como le faltó
nena no daba pero lo que sí te puedo
garantizar es que aunque lo hubiera ido
muy bien no la pasó para nada bien y hoy
ya se debe haber olvidado un montón de
cosas muchas de las cosas que hacen los
adultos para motivar a los chicos hace
que no quieran aprender
el show de los talentos en donde de
repente uno está adelante sí y los demás
están atrás y la verdad que no la pasan
nada bien el cuadro de honor o la
terrible comparación tu hermano sí que
entendía rápido
muchas de las cosas que hacen los
adultos para motivar a los chicos hace
que no quieran aprender y este es uno de
los problemas que tenemos en la
educación actual que el foco está
siempre puesto en aprobar en la nota
pero no en aprender y esto te quiero
hablar hoy entonces un ratito que te
quiero contar primero que tenemos buenas
noticias porque porque hoy sabemos
muchísimo acerca del cerebro que antes
tal vez no se sabía pero mira lo que
pasa
un chico estudia rinde y aprueba y a los
tres días que pasó se olvidó de
absolutamente todo porque por dos
motivos primero porque no sabe cómo
hacer para que esa información llegue
realmente a la memoria de largo plazo
qué significa esto que aprender es
meterse cosas en la cabeza pero poder
evocar las cuando las necesito ahora si
yo sólo me acuerdo a los tres días para
rendir un examen y después me olvido y
claramente esa información nunca llegó a
la memoria de largo plazo quedó en otra
memoria en una memoria ponele intermedia
y además que es lo que pasa muchos
chicos estudian la noche anterior y van
a rendir y aprueban
o sea que el sistema parece que le
funciona pero en radiales funciona para
que para probar pero no para aprender
nosotros tenemos que entender que
educación tiene que cambiar y tenemos
que volver a poner el foco en el placer
por aprender en que en poder trabajar
con lo que es la curiosidad la
creatividad la innovación y por sobre
todas las cosas en esas habilidades
socio emocionales que nos exige el siglo
21 antes de estudiar tenía que ver con
memorizar datos fechas hechos hoy
sabemos que si la clase no es lo más
memorable posible los chicos se
desconectan empiezan a pensar en otras
cosas tenemos que hacer que lo que
enseñemos tenga sentido porque porque
estamos compitiendo con netflix estamos
compitiendo con la xbox estamos
compitiendo con un montón de cosas que
son muy pero muy interesantes si el
chico en la mitad de la clase no se
puede contestar la pregunta de esto para
qué me sirve seguramente se va a
desconectar pero que te quiero explicar
hoy que el potencial es algo a lo que
podemos aspirar si nosotros hoy sabemos
que podemos llegar a nuestro mayor
potencial eso quiere decir que si yo me
exijo puedo
a jugar al tenis como federer no pero
federer puede jugar al tenis de la mejor
manera posible dependiendo de su
potencial lo que yo sí puedo hacer es
llegar a mi potencial y lo que tu hijo
puede hacer es llegar a su mayor
potencial pero de vuelta lamentablemente
el sistema educativo no impulsa que
lleguen a su mayor potencial porque les
toman una prueba muchos chicos miran la
nota vence aprobaron o no y la tiran a
la basura o la guardan no quieren ver en
qué se confundieron o que hicieron bien
o muchas veces les devolvemos una prueba
los chicos qué pasa se sacaron un 3
bueno tema nuevo y avanzamos y nunca le
doy la posibilidad al alumno de hacer
una aproximación sucesiva que es de a
poquito ir avanzando cada vez más te
vuelvo a contar del colegio y de
educación física para que termines de
verlo frustrada que quede con toda esta
situación en mi colegio teníamos que
correr en la secundaria 12 minutos les
pasó alguna vez esto 12 minutos entonces
había que salir a correr esos 26 minutos
e imaginarme yo alguna cosa no cambiaron
demasiado no podía correr esos 12
minutos
arbusto que había en mi colegio me
conoció porque me escondí atrás de cada
uno hasta que un día me descubrieron
otro día te digo que paso pero si mi
profesora me hubiera dicho laura
corriente 3 a 33 y yo corría 3 y corría
3 varias veces más hasta que un día tal
vez corría 6 y un día porque no 9 y un
día porque no los 12 que tenía que
correr y si me sorprendí a mí misma e
inclusive corría más de 20 minutos pero
nadie me lo pidió se suponía que todos
teníamos que ser perfectos la primera
vez que la primera vez tenías que hacer
las cosas bien y cuando hacemos esto
estamos enviando una lección horrible a
nuestros hijos horribles a nuestros
alumnos y es que todos tenemos que ser
perfectos la primera vez y saber lo que
es aprender aprender es estar en un es
estar en una curva de aprendizaje donde
vamos avanzando y avanzamos y avanzamos
cada uno a su propio ritmo cada uno a su
propia manera y eso es lo importante
personalizar la educación para que cada
uno sienta que puede no que no puede
seguir acompañándolos entonces me
acuerdo y ahora te voy a contar algo
te va a divertir me acuerdo que estaba
viendo tele la vez pasada vi que estos
programas de talento que en diferentes
países estaban pasando uno de talento de
australia y me acuerdo que bien chicos
que se llamaba jonathan y mientras
hablaba en entrevista previa temblaba
temblaba como una hoja y alguien le
pregunta por qué está tan nervioso y él
cuenta que hace muchísimos años quiere
participar de esta competencia pero que
no se animaba y es más cinco veces
consecutivas había completado el
formulario para ingresar y lo había roto
porque sentía que no podía la cuestión
es que en ese año si logra hacerlo y
canta y bolo escuchas cantar y canta
como los dioses y se te pone la piel de
gallina y vos no podés no pensar quién
le dijo a este chico que no podía cantar
pero alguien le dijo que no podía cantar
y mira cómo se empieza a relacionar todo
un día ni está este año tercer grado
tiene dictado de letra h todas las
palabras o muchas palabras que empiezan
con h tiene que ser malo para tomar un
dictado de h o sea si no está
contextualizado como estudia si la h es
azarosa
este estudio es el diccionario de
memoria o sea como hacéis para probar un
dictado de letra h es mira me dice que
si es muy difícil o no y más en tercer
grado la cuestión es que anita que
realmente es muy buena alumbra y es
bastante autónoma ni el colegio va a su
dictado para hacer el dictado de la
letra h lo termina y cuando ya está al
día siguiente se lo devuelven la maestra
le dice anita que fue tan pero tan pero
tan mal que no tengo nota para ponerte
anita que hace vuelva al banco me cuenta
y hace esto y la maestra le dice y no te
vas a poner a llorar ahora no cuando
anita llega a casa y nos cuenta
empezamos a empoderar un poquito bromea
lo que pasó después tenía que estudiar
para matemática 'miguel de vuelta le
quiso enseñar y te juro que anita le
gusta estudiar con miguel y no quería
saber nada se empezó olvidar la carpeta
en el colegio y además empezó a decir
que no quería ir al colegio que le dolió
la panza que abría la cabeza que tenía
sueño y decidimos que era hora de ir a
hablar al colegio para poder recompensar
esta situación para volver a encauzar
esta situación vamos a hablar con la
maestra que es amorosa y la conocemos y
la maestra nos dice yo les pido
disculpas pero realmente no tengo ni
registro de haber dicho esto y esto a mí
me hizo pensar en tres cosas número uno
cuando yo le digo a un alumno te fue tan
pero tan mal que no tengo nota para
ponerte en donde estoy haciendo foco en
aprender o en aprobar ya se complicó el
tema de educación
el foco siempre en aprender a probar es
una consecuencia a probar viene con
añadidura
por añadidura número dos cuando le digo
y no te vas a poner a llorar no qué
mensaje estoy diciendo que hay emociones
que no están buenas y todas las
emociones son buenas porque nos dan
información la emoción es algo que es
primitivo que es espontáneo viene y nace
yo no puedo decir no tengas miedo y si
empiezas a tener miedo tenés que
transitar ese proceso lo que sí puedo
hacer es acompañarte lo que sí puedo
hacer es enseñarte a descubrir esa
emoción y autorregular la lo que no
puedo decirte que está mal tener miedo o
está mal estar
no te pongas triste mira es eso el
bonito no tienes que ponerte triste a
ver sonreír
qué mensaje te estoy dando de no te
pongas triste sí que está mal ponerse
triste y eso no es correcto entonces lo
segundo o lo tercero en realidad que me
llamó la atención es cuando ella dijo no
me di cuenta no tengo registro de haber
dicho esto de la misma manera que muchas
veces hacemos cosas tan pero tan
positivas y tan buenas sin darnos cuenta
podemos hacer muchas cosas sin darnos
cuenta que sean dañinas para nuestros
hijos o para nuestros alumnos
entonces para ir redondeando un
poquitito que te quiero contar
importantísimo en el colegio trabajar no
sólo lo cognitivo sino también lo
socio-emocional vos tenés que trabajar
que en este caso en particular el manejo
de la frustración sí sí yo a los chicos
no les enseñó a manejar la frustración a
manejar el fracaso con dignidad se van a
convertir en adultos que no van a creer
en sus habilidades de que de esforzarse
y perseverar para tener éxito yo quiero
que mi hija se frustre pero para no voy
por la vida que se frustre que se
frustre pero cada situación que a mí me
da la vida en donde ella se frustra me
ayuda a mí como mamá a darle
para trabajar lo más importante que
puedes enseñarle a tu hijo cuando es
chiquito y es trabajar la resiliencia
emocional y la resiliencia es volver de
un error volver de algo que hiciste mal
con dignidad con respeto por vos misma y
seguir adelante entonces que te quiero
contar con esto que el éxito no es un
camino lineal el éxito es un zigzag te
caes te levantas volvés a intentarlo
si pensé en gente genial como bolt
disney como shakespeare como einstein
como alguien que conozcas que hace las
mejores empanadas del mundo o la mejor
torta del mundo lo que marca la
diferencia de ellos con tal vez otras
personas no es únicamente su talento es
además la manera en la que ellos se
paran en la vida y como maneja los
desafíos y los obstáculos que te quiero
enseñar muy pero muy rápido para que
trabajes con tus hijos y tus alumnos a
trabajar todo lo que tiene que ver con
habilidades socio emocionales desde
chiquititos la frustración trabaja
poniendo foco en aprender y no en
aprobar usa la palabra mágica todavía no
me sale no te sale todavía no puedo no
podés todavía y cuando se empezó a
incorporar todo esto
sabes qué va a pasar va a empezar a
cambiar muchísimas cosas en la educación
de tus hijos y yo sé que lo que te pido
es muy difícil pero también sé que es
muy importante por mi hija ni está por
tus hijos y por una generación de chicos
que queremos sean fuertes y felices
muchísimas gracias
[Música]
ah
o no